alright meltem we've got a lot to get
through
[Laughter]
yeah we we had a great warm-up before we
turned on the recording so it should be
fun let's go over real quick for people
who don't know just your background and
then we can dig into all of the
controversial ideas that I'm sure you're
excited to talk about I don't think
they're controversial they're just you
know thoughtful I hope but we can debate
the merits of that so look I don't want
to be boring so I math in finance
background started my career in the oil
and gas industry during the onshore
shale boom have seen what irrational
bubbles look like from the inside of
some of the world's largest corporations
focused primarily on oil and gas M&A oil
and gas strategy and then decided to go
as a consultant decide to go in-house
ExxonMobil worked for the treasurer of
the corporation there and got to sort of
see the inner workings of which at the
time the world's largest corporation
she's really interesting learned a lot
there I went to business school at MIT
did a lot of work there on kind of the
FinTech start-up wave that's starting
around 2012-2013 got into the venturi
space and really just saw so many
interesting problems in venture with
incentives between investors and
entrepreneurs had been bitten by the
Bitcoin bug and then met Barry Silbert
had been working on this idea called
digital currency group joined him in
2015 to build that out spent three years
there took the firm from twenty
portfolio companies to 120 built a bunch
of great businesses did a lot of really
interesting things and also was there
really for the move from Bitcoin only to
enterprise blockchain then to tokens and
now it's back to blockchains via
security tokens so it's been interesting
being a part of that evolution and
really being involved in many different
parts of the ecosystem now what I do is
I'm at coin shares which is a digital
asset management business I'm really
focused on building the next generation
of financial products and services for
retail investors institutional investors
and most importantly the crypto space we
need to start bringing more
institutional asset management
principles into this end
to really make it credible in an
investable asset class and it needs to
be done in a way that is kind of true to
the principles of crypto but also
incorporates the last 150 years of
knowledge around corporate finance
behavioral finance incentives etc
absolutely what um what originally drew
dab it coin what why Bitcoin yes the
original draw to Bitcoin was I needed to
send a transaction and I needed to send
it to a market where there was no real
banking infrastructure my family's from
Turkey originally and I looked at a
bunch of different options and one of my
friends like Oh have you heard of
Bitcoin and so I went on Reddit and I
went to our slash Bitcoin and I was like
wow there's a lot to unpack here this is
wild it's weird I had to then get
bitcoins so I pinged my brother who you
know he and I grew up playing video
games together he's a programmer and a
developer so he's always kind of on the
bleeding edge of these things and he's
like yeah local bitcoins calm so I went
on local bitcoins and I met someone in a
parking lot and it felt like a drug deal
but it was a Bitcoin deal which was
pretty exciting and from there just the
more I started learning the more
interested I became luckily in grad
school I had a lot of free time I was at
MIT where there was a lot of work going
on on campus with students who are you
know mining in their dorm rooms some
students got sued by the state of New
Jersey for running an illegal lottery
because they were running a Bitcoin
faucet so just really fun really
interesting and then the whole crypto
anarchist thing just add an extra layer
of interest I never really thought about
the relationship between money power
politics and societal structure and
citing for me that was really a moment
where I started to just become a lot
more aware of what was happening in the
world and the implications of changing
the structure of how how many works
absolutely
it's um I think not talked about enough
that now is just a technology solution
right but it's also opening the mind and
really drawing attention from a
psychological standpoint what what do
you think is the most misunderstood
concept in crypto
I I do think the word D says so there
are two things that really trouble me I
make this comment often and say a lot of
times when people who are new to the
crypto space and who are skeptical enter
the crypto space are gonna meet up or a
conference what they say is I feel like
I walked into a dystopian Ayn Rand novel
filled with 25 year old white dudes and
look that's not a criticism oh I just
got it I just got a checkmark I think we
have 225 no the white but look here's
here's the two things I think we do that
don't really translate well and to the
point you made earlier about this being
psychological the way I would phrase
that is this is a battle for hearts and
minds right if we look at innovations if
we look at big shifts in structure in
human history it's really about moving
hearts and minds and I think we're
missing that a bit right now
the first concept that's really overused
is this word decentralization and
decentralization means many different
things you'd have decentralization at
the protocol level both from the
distribution of wealth so kind of a Gini
coefficient analysis as well as the
distribution of power and who gets to
write the code and set the rules and
we're seeing that being challenged you
know Bitcoin huge power struggle all the
time
cerium has Vitalik who more or less has
been their anointed leader and I think
every protocol kind of struggles with
decentralization then you have the
networking layer decentralization so
mining power how that's distributed
staking power how that's distributed and
that the application layer are there a
lot of different entities producing
applications are those applications
decentralized that word is so poorly
defined and it's used as an ad hominem
attack on projects without any
qualifications so I think that's one
kind of concept that we use a lot that
we don't really articulate very well I
think the second component is there is
this moralistic bent the crypto
community has where I think a lot of
people who adopted Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies early they have become
wealthy they've gained independence of
thought through luck and some degree of
conviction
but I think for a lot of people is
really luck being in the right place at
the right time and they've now started
to attribute that to intelligence and
some sort of moral superiority and I
think that's the troubling narrative and
it's also not a very inclusive narrative
so I think for people for hearts and
minds to really shift we need to start
moving away from this moral high-ground
and really start thinking about okay
what does the next billion Bitcoin users
look like and how do we get to that
point it's probably not by talking about
decentralization and you know all of
these political and economic principles
by giving people something they can use
that makes their life better in some way
absolutely I think that's fair so let's
go back first to this idea of
decentralization right in non crypto you
know technology the idea of a founder
being able to you know really Drive go
through obstacles recruit people and set
this vision that we've kind of made it
you know really sexy to be a founder
right it's really crappy you're like you
haven't showered in a week you haven't
eaten a proper meal you have no idea
what's going on you're emotionally
exhausted you're constantly living
between a state of euphoria and like
tremendous soul-crushing anxiety but yes
it's the duck analogy right so if you
look at a duck in water above the water
they're cool calm and collected below
water they're just paddling as fast as
they possibly can as they don't drown
right but but you know in this
decentralized world this idea that there
is no leader right and and you don't
need to have a single point of failure
or that you know threat component how do
you think founders and leadership play
into a decentralized world and is it
important that's a really interesting
question I don't think I have a
definitive answer but I gotten going
back to this idea of hearts and minds
and how humans operate I think that
people are drawn to characters even
though the crypto community to some
degree tries to be decentralized it's
really interesting
is we have a very strong cast of
characters they're very opinionated and
very loud what I think it goes back to
ultimately is look I've been in the
venture space for quite some time
and what's what's interesting about it
is in the venture space the way that
founders operate you're running a
company right companies require
organization and the reason that the
corporate form was created it's really
just a governance structure right
because establishing contracts for every
single piece of work every single
transaction doesn't make sense so the
corporate form was created to line
incentives between investors employees
managers stakeholders in that entity and
they're all incentivized to work
together to reduce a common set of goals
and that's reinforced by legal contracts
financial incentives and the terms of
shareholder value and bonus structures
and how people get compensated and it's
taken us 200 years to get to a workable
corporate form right and we see that
reflected in the size of the equities
market people are willing to put
trillions of dollars into that corporate
form in the form of investing in stock
what's interesting about crypto is there
is no such form right the crypto firm
are what I like to call the theory of
the crypto firm is highly immature
because this is this is new but what we
see is people are trying to replicate
things that have existed in the
corporate form for the last two
centuries in the crypto firm and it
doesn't quite work because right now if
you're an investor and you're putting
capital into a crypto firm or someone
who's capitalizing their company through
token you have no rights you know pref
inner preferences there are no covenants
there's no legal contract that binds
that founder to do anything on your
behalf and what you then see is their
tremendous abuses of power there's
tremendous degree of moral hazard and I
think I don't mean that to say that
people set out with that intent I just
think the form were using is perhaps not
appropriate for what we're trying to do
so I think the narrative around security
tokens is really compelling because
investors can understand that
but when you say to someone if you read
the terms of some of these tokens um no
there's a disclaimer in every token sale
that says you've no rights you're not
entitled to anything
we're not promising that we'll give you
anything so the idea that we're gonna
give people billions of dollars on the
basis of social trust I think is an
imperfect idea because block chains
don't change human nature absolutely
well and I think that what's interesting
is you know people forget that these
security started out looking very
different right so when equity was first
you know created and somebody said I'll
give you money to run this company it
wasn't for enterprise value to then go
public or to be acquired it was
literally a claim on cash flows right
and so that it's almost like we're
coming full circle to some degree with
you know all this Unchained governance
or claim to you know transaction fees
etc in the blockchain world how much of
that do you think can be solved by
technology versus the psychology that's
a really great point and I think that's
probably a great way to summarize what I
just spent five minutes articulating so
I think what's interesting here is you
have a lot of people a lot of the people
in the crypto space are working on these
ideas tend to be younger I think a lot
of them haven't worked in corporate
structures before and that's not a bad
thing there's a lot of value in
experimentation and innovation because
you can learn things that can be applied
at scale I think the challenge here is
is that the learning process has gotten
a bit bastardized because we are
building things that are highly
imperfect that are very flawed in a lot
of different ways both from a technical
perspective governments perspective and
actual scalability and implementation
perspective a practical application
perspective yet these projects are being
capitalized at valuations that exceed
the average IPO by a factor of 10 yep
right and so I think we kind of have
created this false sense of success
where people feel hey I'm able to raise
a shit-ton of capital it's literally a
shit-ton and they have no plan on how to
deploy it and I think the interesting
conversation I have with founder
he's one of the things I've been focused
on is helping people with treasury
management is um there's a difference
between need and want right so maybe I
need fifteen million dollars to build
this idea but the market wants to give
me five hundred million so what are you
yeah exactly in black chains don't
change human nature right there's a lot
of ego involved that's a this crypto
environment right now the narrative is
so focused on price and how much money
was raised that we're kind of getting to
that stage where I think the money needs
to get flushed out of it and we need to
go back to building and this goes right
along with Carlotta Perez's research
around capital formation bubbles and how
that corresponds with technical
innovation cycles but a lot of this is
we have this technology but can we
articulate a clear reason that this
technology needs to be utilized for
things that we already do in the
existing world and I think that
narrative just isn't there yet
it's the trade-off between because
there's so many technologists right they
want about technology I called like the
hacker mentality of they're you know
they're tinkering they make technology
do something that they haven't seen
before or it's faster it's better or
whatever and they start showing people
people get excited but I think there's
too much focus on that technology and
instead if you look at it the opposite
side say let's look at it from user
behavior right now the user actually
doesn't care what's under the hood right
the or there's some users that will
write obviously it's some small subset
but but the mass consumer mass user
doesn't actually care what that
technology is they just want to
accomplish what they're trying to do
with the best technology but I think
this is part of the challenge when you
have a movement that really started with
engineering and technology is you have a
bunch of developers and engineers who
for the first time are discovering
finance and they're saying oh we can
treat finance like code and there's an
input and then there's a contract and
then there's output
and the thing is like you and I worked
in traditional finance that's not how
people think people don't respond to an
input function with particular output
and I think my friend Jill Carlson says
it best it's not you put in a token you
get out in action
that's not how incentives and systems
work it's a little bit more complex than
that because human beings react to
emotion human beings I think are
fundamentally irrational and again
behavioral finance is a field of study
that's only really you know half a
century olds 50 60 years old and we're
still learning a lot look at what
happened in 2008 not a lot of people saw
that coming look at what happens in
individual asset classes we have all
these great ideas and what we see is the
breakdown of markets I'm look at the
equities market right now look at the
fangs right it's an imperfect science
but I think treating crypto like a math
problem treating it like an engineering
problem treating finance and money in
that manner is interesting but I don't
think that works and so I think the next
five to ten years are probably going to
be spent trying to figure out how to
integrate other disciplines into so I
think that an example where the finance
community has previously treated money
and finance as a math equation or math
game right is with CD it was like cap em
and whack and DCF and all these
valuation models like well so if we go
to the CEOs right you recently said you
know stable coins are basically the CEOs
of crypto explain what you mean by that
right so I think here's the problem is
the crypto community has latched on we
tend to latch on to narratives and then
we work through a narrative for six to
nine months right so the narrative that
started developing last year was oh the
reason that people don't wanna invest in
crypto because it's too volatile and
moving into and out of Fiat is too
difficult and so people started saying
why don't we create this concept of a
stable coin and we've already seen
iterations of it I think part of the
impetus frankly was the fact that tether
was so successful and so widely adopted
that it kind of shocked everyone
um but I think the problem with stable
coins now and now every platform is
launching their own stable coin right so
you have collateral back stable coins
like tether or like digits which is
backed by gold then you have
collateralized stable coins that things
like maker or Haven that rely on kind of
a two coin system where you can redeem
or create the stable coin through
secondary mechanism and then you have
the idea of a programmatic quote-unquote
decentralized almost decentralized Bank
structure or sovereign issuance
structure where people are issuing
assets then there's complex governance
structure and I think the problem is
this is number one the thesis as to why
steeple stable coins need to exist has
not been proven true right it's same
problem with that protocols like that
caught on and then we saw billions of
dollars of financing flow into
nonsensical protocols because everyone
was so addicted to this idea of fad
protocols
I think we've the same narrative with
stable coins where we're creating this
false narrative in our minds because at
first blush it makes sense so it's like
if a then B therefore C must be true and
we know that's not always true so what I
think we're doing is we're number one
we're financing stable coins through an
investment structure that doesn't align
incentives right so going to an investor
and saying hey if you buy this asset
early on then you're gonna get to
participate in value creation or in the
flow of payments through this network
like that doesn't really work no one's
paying the Fed to create killers saying
that's a weird structure and I think
again what we're doing is we're creating
all of this systemic risk right because
now we have stable coins on protocols
and then on top of the stable coins
there are more coins like it's coins all
the way down point Quinn Quinn Quinn
Quinn and the thing is at some point we
stopped being able to untangle how any
of this works and the degree of systemic
risk and the system is already so
incredibly high you think about the fact
that Zappo custody is 10% or more of the
world's Bitcoin you think about the fact
that coin base holds a lot of crypto
assets you think about the fact that
finance probably hosts 50% of traded
volume and all assets right we already
have a lot of systemic risk we don't
need to layer in 50 to a hundred to one
hundred fifty different stable coins
that are all abstractions of themselves
with no governance structure no audit
ability
and frankly like no one has the appetite
to monitor this [ __ ] either yep
necessary part of it too is it and I
think we agree that if you have a
heavily an engineer heavy team or a
finance heavy team right you're at a
disadvantage than the team that is more
diverse right so having a combination of
people who come from the engineering
world from the technology in product
world from finance from design etc by
bringing all those people together you
get different experiences different
perspectives different knowledge bases
and so the product is probably going to
be much more usable right and also
technically sound it's kind of the
theory the other piece I'll just add to
that is I think it helps to have people
with different backgrounds and different
experience what I always like to say is
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes and
I think a lot of times when people come
in and they pitch an idea to me I'm like
that's interesting but this has been
done 50 times before have you gone back
and just looked at him looked at it and
so I think sometimes we sort of jump on
ideas because of the newness of the idea
when in fact it's really just an
iteration of what's already being done
in other industries so I think there's a
little bit of intellectual arrogance in
the crypto community and I myself I
think when I started in Bitcoin was
probably guilty of it and I was you know
a little bit of an [ __ ] but as I've
learned I've really started to
appreciate when I go into meetings now
with people outside the crypto space I
actually spend most of the time not
talking I spend most of their time just
asking questions and trying to
understand someone's mental model and so
in that where do you think crypto assets
sit in a traditional capital allocators
portfolio how are they thinking about
that right now yeah so I just put out
some some content around this and
hopefully in the next few days we'll
push out a longer rapport with a lot of
great data in it look if we look at this
institutional investor class there's
about in the u.s. there's about 28
trillion dollars of institutional AUM
and that's mostly pensions but that's
endowments family offices hedge funds
venture funds
firms crypto market cap is 220 250
billions or on daily basis right now and
so what I what I think is challenging is
right now those those firms are
allocating to low-risk securities right
so Chih bills strips bonds Sara that's a
small percent of their portfolio
they've cash money market stuff they
have traditional equities they have real
estate and then maybe 15% of their
portfolio is in higher risk assets that
focus on early stage capital formation
the growth stage capital formation so
that's growth equity and PE it's hedge
funds and it's venture and so as we look
at that where do crypto assets fit in
monetary instruments probably the
closest analogue to something like a
Bitcoin okay so that's more like your
money market bucket real estate that's
probably more like securitized assets
right so can we securitize assets and
make them more flexible maybe equities
that's more like token offerings that
represent equity and privately held
companies write that kind of displace is
that PE bucket I SEOs probably fit more
into the VC bucket where it's really
early stage idea is getting capitalized
so I'm trying to think of in the context
of an institutional investor is what are
those analogues because they think there
may be new capital that flows in but
likely it's more of a displacement of
existing allocations into some of these
new asset classes and I think what's
challenging there is you have to frame
the narrative in a way where an
institutional investor a understands
what they're buying it fits into the
mental models they have that have been
trained you know over the last 50 years
and then they also have to be able to
hold it
trade it deal with it talk about it to
their investors in an easy way and I
think that's where the market
infrastructure side is a little immature
we've been so focused on the creation
and distribution of assets that we
really haven't started thinking about
the management of assets so that post
investment lifecycle is pretty
underdeveloped and then end-of-life of
an asset right so what happens when a
token is dead how do you redeem a token
back into cash what do you get so
there's gonna be a lot of
experimentation but I think the slice of
the pie that's gonna go into
cryptocurrencies true store value
cryptocurrencies I SEOs security tokens
and securitized assets is initially
going to be much smaller than we
imagined but then when we start being
able to prove that in fact that
efficiency that liquidity and that sort
of usability component that we talked
about can actually be realized once
there's proof of that
I think it'll grow much more quickly but
we're not doing a very good job right
now so I definitely agree with that and
I think that what one hope of a lot of
people in crypto world is that some of
these traditional legacy players can
come in and legitimize the space right
and so ice for example coming in and
saying hey we're gonna create this
platform right we're gonna kind of put
our name our experience behind this how
do you think that impacts this space not
only from the development of crypto
assets and networks but then also from
the institutional investors perspective
yes I think the ice announcement is one
that I'm still processing in one way I
do think it's really good because it
adds legitimacy to the space I think
particularly big coin right Bitcoin is
that asset that it's been in the market
long enough there's enough data around
that investors are starting to get more
comfortable with the idea of bitcoins I
think that's familiar
exactly right but also that body of
knowledge exists and we now know how to
deal with it most importantly you know
how to value it and mark it I think
that's a huge problem we don't really
talk about as much so bitcoins starting
to feel familiar so ice coming out and
saying look we're gonna enable you to
really easily with a trusted partner
that you already can trade with is all
Bitcoin like that's that's material I
think the hard part is is once the
financial institutions start moving in
they're gonna do what they do right like
banks got a bank so people started
talking to you now about the idea of
extending leverage on top of Bitcoin and
I'm like oh it's coming oh [ __ ] not
gonna go like that's the antithesis of
why Bitcoin was created
so I do think there's this component and
what I always say is there's the
revolution camp which is where I started
out when I got into Bitcoin like down
with the banks like [ __ ] the
institutions and that's one narrative
and then there's the evolution narrative
which is hey we're gonna start with
something that looks smells tastes feels
like what's already happening in the
world of institutional finance and then
over time it will involve inform to be
more reflective of all the technical
capabilities of a blockchain based asset
or come to currency which which do you
think is more likely to occur today the
Revolution or the evolution okay so here
it actually depends on the broader macro
environment which is something I don't
think we think about often inside the
crypto bubble if we have another 2008 if
we have another Cypress or another
Greece then I think we're gonna go
revolution and the thing I always think
about is are we ready right like when
that narrative starts to really
accelerate and when people have that
impetus when there's that Matt what I
was thinking
so if we stay on the current path we're
gonna go evolution but if there is a
massive force that jolts us out of that
path then we're gonna go revolution so
this is fascinating because somebody
asked me recently what did I think would
get us out of this bear market right I
said there's gotta be some kind of
catalyst right that will that will
create some inflection point and I said
you know it's a retail product that's
one option not necessary because I think
people have a hard time buying Bitcoin
but it's more of the legitimacy
Insurance custody all that kind of stuff
another could be that you know it's just
some huge institution reveals that
they've got you know a position that no
one knows about right so if you know a
sovereign wolf comes out says listen
we've bought you know billions of
dollars worth of Bitcoin right something
like that where again you just get a
bunch of legitimacy but the Third Point
happened then like capital inflows you
know that would really drastically yeah
well and so here's the third one and
actually what I think doesn't get talked
a lot about and you just mentioned so
it's worth spending time on is if there
is an economic chaos that occurs in a
specific region or country that causes
people to flow into Bitcoin for example
because it is the best option available
it's almost like we get a watch it
as an example hearts and minds right yes
I don't think it even has to be economic
I think if we look at the political
climate in a lot of economies we look
you know globalization was the theme in
the 1990s and the 2000s and now what we
started to see is like yes globalization
has changed the world
integrated markets more efficient
markets more assets more capital more
cash has lifted a lot of people out of
poverty like objectively speaking if we
look at the data
people are living a better quality of
life there is more wealth in our world
than there was in the past but
inequality has grown and I think this is
the the challenging part is a lot of
what's happening it's social there's a
lot of social unrest there's a lot of
political unrest and there's a lot of
uncertainty and fear even in even with
investors absolutely we look at what's
happening in equities like the the Dow
hit 25,000 and everyone's like peak peak
fell liquidate what are we gonna do and
it kept going up everything feels
overvalued you look at real estate real
estate feels over bought VC everything's
overvalued and so investors are looking
at the world this macro environment
they're like in a world where everything
feels overvalued and overbought in a
world where we're really not sure where
alpha is gonna come from what do we do
absolutely I think that creates a lot of
room and I think again what we as an
industry need to start to think about is
how do we win hearts and minds this is
uh this is where the virus is spreading
rays came front literally the the
thought process was I originally said
one of bitcoins greatest qualities is
that it's captured I said the mental
energy of a generation right people were
so excited and the talent was flowing
into the space the capital was flowing
into the space and so you get these boom
and bust cycles but innovation follows
that town in capital right because
there's just so much mental energy being
applied to but I what I'm worried about
is like we look at what happened with
retail in late 2017 early 2000
and 18 and this is what I worry about is
a ton of retail investors got crushed
absolutely and I think the hard part is
those people aren't gonna come back for
a while because their trust has been
destroyed and we did it through this
financing vehicle where we created a
bunch of wealth under the guise of
decentralization that really flowed into
the hands of a few people and you see
this right reflected in like all these
crypto conferences and like people going
to exotic locations and living really
lavish lifestyles and then this gets
glamorized which brings in you know less
educated wave of retail and I find that
a bit problematic the crypto has a
little bit of an image problem and yes
like the sexiness like the sex drugs
rock and roll appeal of crypto is
definitely there
but I think it's a double-edged sword
because a lot of people have gotten
really burned and I think a lot of
people look at it and they're like yep
well if you think in the last 12 months
so we're doing this August 2018 so
August 17 right is really when I think
kind of the more mainstream audience
sort of to at least hear about it and
then you go into October really November
December and then you look at the price
depreciation since those days there's a
possibility that more people lost money
investing in Bitcoin the last 12 months
then made money right on an aggregate
number of investors absolutely I have so
many stories from retail investors and
institutional investors by the way who
really got burned and I think part of
the problem here is on people like
stories right where humans have an rich
oral history because we tell stories
that's how we share information that's
how we connect with other people so the
story around crypto up until January
2018 was this everyone had a friend or
someone they knew who bought Bitcoin
early or who bought cerium early and
they asked that they bought went from X
to Y and that Delta was you know
thousand twelve thousand percent five
thousand percent and so people look at
that and they're like ooh Bitcoin
aetherium Ripple people got into these
assets early that have been around for
five or six years
they made 100 X 200 X a thousand X their
money I want to do that and then all of
these i ciose are pitching
where the next aetherium we're like
bitcoin but better and so people buy it
yep and then that doesn't materialize
and I think this is the problem with
growth stories right and this is the way
equities market really you see it happen
there as well I'm it kind of reminds me
of penny stocks absolutely know it and
part of it is your trading or gambling
right you know that if you look at a
hundred of them but you get to say
you're in a tech investor right like
it's a gamble full time I love gambling
I'm a degenerate I tell people I tell
people that you can't you can't claim
you're investing if you don't have a
thesis you don't have underwritten the
risk and you don't have a price target
well and I think this so this actually
is a really good point
so people are so focused and investing
and this is true venture as well right I
worked a lot on the post investment side
people are so focused on everything up
to the point of writing a check and then
once they write the check they're like
okay my work is done no no actually your
most important job as an investor one
the investing process is about
controlling entry price yeah and it's
articulating a thesis and a strategy as
an investor but as a fiduciary your
primary responsibility is that post
investment life cycle you have to
monetize it how do you track the status
of these projects right how do you
articulate a cogent thesis on where your
liquidation points are and how do you
periodically rebalance and do risk and
take out some of the principal and then
reinvest how do you think about your
role in the governance of these
companies that you're capitalizing and
was so funny to me he's like I've been
doing this in the venture world with the
portfolio companies I've been working
with for the last five years and now I'm
crypto funds are like oh like maybe we
have to be partners to these projects
I'm like I feel like I'm taking crazy
like am I taking crazy pills um I think
so it's just really interesting the
naivete and just and again I sound like
a skeptic but I just I feel like we're
not learning lessons I feel like we're
so unwilling to accept fundamental
truths about human nature
now we're forgetting that like hey when
you write a check like what's part of
the revolution right is if you go from
you know step one to step 7
you don't get the benefit of learning
what two three four five and six
actually the other thing is people have
gotten away with free riding right both
in their diligence process some people
are like oh if Andreessen invested a few
and USV invested i'm in amazing so
that's there's free riding on the
investment process side where people
basically do no work and are able to
race crypto funds and then the second
component is there's a lot of free
riding in the post investment process
and I have is in traditional venture
which why everyone's like Oh find a
strong lead because I don't want to do
the work let's have someone else who is
more capitalist to do the work to help
you grow something in crypto world right
Lee and the problem is when you have a
bunch of investors who are free riding
off of everyone else and they don't
actually own equity they just own tokens
which are liquid right away what's the
incentive to actually help people
long-term and this I feel bad for
projects who raise money from investors
they basically sold their souls to raise
this money and then as soon as the token
lists everyone dumps the token takes
their cash out and they're trying to
build so they're like passionate about
building a vision and everyone who told
them they were also passion about it
just stopped them they're like cool we
got our cash buy and that's not a good
paradigm either so I do feel bad for
companies who have a big vision we're
trying to build it like that's why I
think a lot of these projects who didn't
set a date for releasing their token
they're probably better served to not
release their token until they've gotten
the max juice out of their investors in
terms of very interesting so okay let's
go to the dark side of crypto three
three things so one is let's talk about
what call air quotes professional
investors right so funds and venture
capital etcetera buying tokens at huge
discounts and not disclosing positions
and then dumping on retail what the [ __ ]
coin waterfalls so so explain kind of
your perspective as to what's been going
on really I think you know some of it
hopefully is dissipating a little bit
but maybe not as fast as we want it to
but but explain kind of how that happens
and then where you think things need to
change sure so I'll quickly describe the
[ __ ] coin
Waterfall it's it's a terrible way of
saying something but um okay so the [ __ ]
coin waterfall is this you get a bunch
of people together and they're like we
want to do this crypto project we're
gonna build a decentralized computing
protocol right great and so they go to a
small group of investors typically
insiders known people in the crypto
space they're like hey we're doing a pre
seed round we're doing like a pre pre
sale we're gonna give you tokens at this
price and everyone writes their checks
and they raise a couple million bucks
great they don't get to go mark it and
hire more people and then they get to a
point where they put out a white paper
or something more articulated to the
market and they go to a bigger group of
investors and institutions they're like
hey who are less who are less on the
inside who are less on the inside right
and they're like hey we're doing a
pre-sale look at the people in this pre
presale they're awesome but we're doing
presale now and we're gonna give you a
price that is 10x what they paid okay
great
so they pay 10x more and then they're
like okay we're gonna do presale bigger
audience less informed you get less
information less insight and they're
like hey we're we're gonna let you in
and it's at 100x what the pre presale
people paid and 10x with the pre sale
people pay so you create this later'd
structure right in this kind of
resembles liquidation preferences yep
right in in a traditional corporation
and so you have this structure and then
you're like okay we're gonna list the
tokens on the market and they have all
these announcements and they're going
around telling their pre pre sale
investors like hey here's our plan
here's we're gonna do here's what's
going on and then the prepuce sale
investors by the way all collaborate
together to say okay we're gonna buy
we're gonna sell they can manipulate the
price of these assets and actually my
research team's been working on
analyzing movement of coins like the
network topology of some of these tokens
through the process of listing and how
that sort of evolves over time there's
some shady [ __ ] people do and what ends
up happening is people start dumping
their coins on the market retail starts
buying it there's this narrative that
gets created like this is an amazing
coin look at how innovative it is look
who backed it look who back to it right
look at the founders this is amazing
this is so phenomenal they do a bunch of
marketing they throw a bunch of events
they do maybe a couple of press releases
or partnerships or announcements where
they're paying people for partnership
and then retail buys up these tokens
everyone's eggs in their position and it
just starts dumping and the thing is the
reason the [ __ ] coin waterfall has
worked historically is because investors
knew there was always a buyer of last
resort who was not them I think in this
market right now because retail has lost
their appetite
there is no buyer of last resort it's
institutions selling bags to one another
and so I think ultimately this just
becomes a game of who gets the most
information the fastest and who can dump
the fastest absolutely well in it now
leads us to a problem of how much
capital inflow is actually going on
versus or we just recycle any funds
right and I think the circularity of
capital is really problematic and you
see this like when I venture funds
invest in a in a crypto protocol they do
niceö they raise money from other VCS
then and take that money and give it to
another VC to invest in more startups
who then create tokens that the VC buys
that then the protocols it's like the
circularity is incredible and I think
part of it is there is no utility for
these tokens
there's speculative assets for ideas
that are poorly implemented in some
cases um and look it's not a criticism I
sympathize with people of really big
visions and are trying to build them but
I think the circularity of capital
problem if everyone's motivated by
financial return what ends up happening
is you have people who have a short time
frame have a short attention span and
the minute that it's no longer worth
spending a minute of time on a project
because you're not going to get any
juice out of it yep they're gone so
alright so got the [ __ ] coin waterfall
yeah let's stay within bad actors in the
investing community so I think the
narrative normally I don't want to use
bad write so bad is a prescriptive word
that imp used some sort of judgment I
don't think it's that people play this
game in every market known a man so so
[ __ ] coin waterfall I don't think is
necessarily bad right as long as there's
some understanding of what's going on
the transparency but yeah the bad actor
I think is the insider traders etc and
where where is that line right because
we've got some commodities some
securities some unknowns and so what ira
specifically aim
is recently New York congressman Wright
was arrested for insider trading actual
insider trading right and so how do you
think about a traditional established
well-governed
market like public equities right we're
obviously people who are in positions of
power right are coming under scrutiny
right example is a great one right like
did Elan must commit some sort of
absolutely by announcing something if we
took that level of scrutiny and applied
it to the crypto markets what's the end
result how much of it do you think is
actually you know bad acting versus hey
these aren't securities they're
commodities like just walk me through
kind of how you think that looks if we
apply that level of scrutiny to crypto
markets okay so first I want to
differentiate between two things there's
the law yep which are a set of written
rules that are enforced by agencies that
have teeth right they can put you in
jail they can find you so there's the
law and then there is a morality which
is very subjective it's cultural in
nature it's something that might be
deemed immoral in the US could be moral
in China or vice versa or another part
of the world so I think separating the
law from morality is important here so
legally speaking the [ __ ] coin waterfall
market manipulation etc it's permissible
there is no agency that has come out and
said here are disclosure standards here
reporting standards here standards for
how you publish research that doesn't
exist yet so legally speaking what
people are doing is permissible under
the current state of regulations and the
markets they're operating in so legally
speaking when there is no threat of
enforcement when there is no threat of
going to jail or getting fined or
getting removed from the investment
community there's no real grit behind
these claims people are making and
you're not doing anything wrong in the
eyes of the law so it will continue
morally speaking I think that's where it
starts to get interesting so if the
premise of crypto is based on moral
arguments around fairness
decentralization these ideals and
principles around the democracy
station of capital then morally speaking
this behavior is inconsistent with the
narrative we're selling to people when
we're selling crypto and that
incompatibility that incongruence makes
the whole asset class really unappealing
and so I think the bigger problem is the
end of because there are no regulations
in law the industry itself needs to set
a standard so last year I created my
standard for transparency disclosure I
also wrote a disclosure policy for
digital currency group around how we
were going to invest in tokens and
announce that and let people know I I
disclosed everything I owned every
company I have an interest in every
project I advised before I get on a
stage I put it all online I updated
every two weeks two months um I think
the biggest thing is intent I will speak
about certain assets I'm excited about
projects but it's important to state to
the general market that I have a
financial interest in these things yep
that's why disclosures exist right now
it's voluntary I would love to see more
people disclosure so it's opt-in and
again I think the industry can create an
environment particularly the investment
community if we can set an internal code
of conduct and if we can sort of raise
the bar for how we conduct ourselves on
the moral side not legally regular
totally one it's gonna change the
perception of this industry but two it's
actually gonna impact the regulators and
lawmakers absolutely because the
perception of the industry will change
of it the question is is are we going to
hold people socially accountable for
committing fraud or violating that moral
code and the problem is there has been
no social cost to being a scammer in the
crypto space well and morality is very
much driven by those around you right
the moral rules are you know unwritten
but they are created and upheld by those
in your community those in your industry
etc and so if you know it's kind of like
you know criminals right there's a code
of conduct silent snitch right but but
and that would be deemed immoral but
obviously the things that they're doing
are illegal right
so once you get into these communities
and I think what you're saying is you
know crypto is very different there's
you know many many many more good actors
than bad actors are people who are
nefarious or malicious but it is up to
yeah that is true but but it is up to
the community itself to enforce those
moral standards and hold people
accountable to some degree for you know
any bad acting et cetera I think the
hard part is what I always like to say
and I know I'm fairly vocal about my
views on things but I'm not the judge
I'm not the jury I'm not an executioner
the only thing I can choose is my
behavior right I have no control over
other people and my only goal and what
I'm doing and the way I talk about what
I'm doing is to just set a standard that
feels right for me and I know personally
what my values are and how I want to
operate and I personally am willing to
forego financial return if it violates
my personal principles not everyone
feels that way and that's fine I'm not
making a judgment as to whether or not
they're a good person or a bad person
I think everyone's incentives are
different but I just want to I'm trying
to point out I'm trying to use facts and
I'm trying to use data-driven evidence
to demonstrate that a lot of what we're
doing here is not going to help us win
hearts and minds and really my goal like
is money important do I like money yes
because it buys me freedom and freedom
means I can do and say whatever I want
which I really kind of enjoy but I think
freedom also comes with responsibility
and I passionately care about Bitcoin in
particular but the broader idea of
cryptocurrencies and this idea of the
democratization of capital I deeply care
about that becoming a reality yep and so
if those two things are true then for me
it creates a responsibility and so I've
chosen to act on that personal sense of
responsibility I feel I think there are
other people in the community who are
doing that I'd love to see that type of
leadership come from the investment
community but I think unfortunately the
investment community you know the reason
people give you capital is to earn a
return and so until we start to see
intent and purpose aligned with
capital formation it's difficult and I
don't begrudge anyone cuz like look
that's your job you can't go to your
investors and say hey like yeah we
didn't dump this token at 50x because
you know hashtag morals
if arguably you're violating your
fiduciary responsibilities to your
investors right so it's a sticky problem
it's a thorny problem
I just think talking about it and
experimenting with it a little bit could
be helpful for us absolutely no I think
that makes sense all right let's go back
to the lighter side of card before we
get there I'm gonna ask you a couple of
questions and be as honest and
controversial as you want I'm never I'm
so afraid of expressing my opinions well
what what is the most controversial
thing that you believe is true that you
think the highest number of people would
disagree with you on in the industry
[Laughter]
okay the best part about this question
is people know what their controversial
thoughts are and so you already know the
top two or three things you want to say
so just say just say number one I think
there is actually a less than zero
percent chance that Bitcoin will not
succeed
interesting explain and that is um
I love Bitcoin it's there's so many
things about Bitcoin that are just
beautiful and just so incredibly well
designed and Satoshi it was just
brilliant and not just in in its
technical design um but the social
design the messaging around it the
political design there's so many things
about Bitcoin that are really elegant
and really interesting like
fundamentally innovative in that they
challenge long-held assumptions about
how humans can collaborate to get
something done which i think is really
interesting but I think the hard part
with Bitcoin I spent a lot of time in
the Bitcoin community from about 2014 to
2000
17 and decentralisation right is one of
these things that's appealing by
centralization creates efficiency
decentralization has a really high cost
and in Bitcoin decentralization has had
a really high social cost and I think
every day that goes by that Bitcoin
continues to operate in this sort of
very unstructured manner is a day that
talent flows to other spaces and
interest flows to other spaces and like
the Bitcoin community doesn't
necessarily do a great job being
communicative it doesn't do a great job
with the hearts and minds piece and I
think the predominant attitude whether
right or wrong is Bitcoin doesn't need
to change you need to change
I think that's unwelcoming and that
that's fine but I think that kind of
approach and its really the ideology in
the mindset of the Bitcoin community
just makes it tough for people to
embrace it so I agree with you that
that's what's happening what if they're
not wrong what what if actually part of
the beauty of Bitcoin is that whether
you like it or not it is a better design
oh absolutely
it's not a flaw of future yeah I'm agree
with that and I think to a hyper
rational person and a thinker who's been
in the space and has the time to really
think about it that works yep some
people who don't have the advantages of
spending time and I think that's the
hard part
and again institutions now getting on
the Bitcoin bandwagon if they become the
mouthpiece that sells Bitcoin to the
broader retail and institutional
community they're gonna completely
bastardize all those ideas and just
steamroll everyone yep and destroy this
beautiful thing we spent ten years
building and so I think either the
Bitcoin community takes more ownership
of the narrative or someone else is
gonna do it for us we're gonna try to do
it and I just I worry about the impact
that we'll have
and that's the problem of social
coordination right that's always been
the problem that's the fundamental
problem Bitcoin itself with Byzantine
fault tolerant consensus mechanism try
to design for and it's um it's a very
hard problem part of it's related to
usability part of it's related to just
the language we use part of it's related
to the relative and maturity of the
tools we have to buy sell trade hold
store learn about Absalon but it's a big
problem what do you think is the most
important company encrypt over the next
10 years I was having this debate with
someone the other day um look I think
bit main has been one of these companies
that like has been so underappreciated
and just has silently built an empire
same thing with bitfury we don't really
talk about mining like these companies
are building next generation not just
Bitcoin infrastructure but compute
infrastructure absolutely um and for
blockchain to work at scale the
networking layer has to be really robust
which is gonna require a lot of like
next-gen compute infrastructure and so
we see the existing fabs are just
starting to get on the asic and GPU
mining bandwagon but these guys have
already been there and so I think that's
that's gonna be really interesting to
watch that battle the other company I
think's really underappreciated I mean
everyone talks about finance and like
how revolutionary finance is actually
think people aren't paying enough
attention to platforms like shaved
shape-shift and abra and really their
mantra is we weren't able users to
transact and invest in trade in a
private secure way these non-custodial
designs I think are really important to
enabling crypto to really spread if we
want to truly create a better financial
system owning your own assets truly
owning your own assets it's really
important and coinbase and finance and
all of these platforms that facilitate
trading they've become central banks
they become points of failure so I think
companies like abre and shape-shift and
others in this vein who are enabling
trading holding storing where you have
full custodial will you full control and
full discretion over what happens really
critical absolutely let's go back to
mining for a second because I think that
your point about how undervalue these
companies
right so the the two things that are top
of mind for me bit made specifically so
one is a lot of people in the crypto
community when they see success right
there's two paths they can go down one
is either they walk right and hey you
know I made a bunch of money and gonna
take it and go enjoy life or the other
is they get really really bold and
ambitious right I think that's what
we're seeing with bit Maine right is
they're saying look we've had a bunch of
success we've been able to drive a bunch
of capital right they when they there
last round they raised I believed that
Outsiders of the company owned less than
5% right all of a sudden now they're
talking a little bit more about
artificial intelligence machine learning
compute that is used for non mining or
non crypto applications and it goes back
to this idea that you know everyone says
date is the new oil right and if data is
the new oil rep in my mouth for everyone
listening right so it's everyone who
says that I always respond with if data
is the new oil computing is the new
steel right because you actually need
the infrastructure to let that whole
data-driven world exist I think the most
underappreciated layer of the crypto
space is the network right so we think
about icos and tokens all the capital
formation is happening at the protocol
layer the application layer it that's or
the V sees like traditional PCs are like
I only do like what are you and they're
investing in applications and then we
see people trying to get around that by
doing these app coin things but no one's
really focusing on that middle layer yep
that enables protocols and technical
design to get implemented in physical
compute space and we see this because
these networks people are building are
not robust like look that's what we'll
look at what's happened with aetherium
look it's happening with es look at like
these new networks that are launching
they're not secure they're not robust
and the problem is is that we're if
we're gonna live in a world with
thousands of block chains they're all
gonna require expression and physical
compute space and where's that
infrastructure gonna come from how
specialized does it need to be and then
does that actually become the new domain
for competition because we can easily
raise capital to protocol area at the
app player but
networking layer there's an actual
physical constraint to implementation
because there's a limited amount of
compute absolutely and so to me
investing in compute and I want to
create structured products that offer
compute capacity to protocols like if
you raise money through an IC o---- for
your protocol you should be buying
compute with that money you should be
buying dedicated networking
infrastructure that's resilient and
robust and that is secure nd risk so
that your protocol can run in all sorts
of adversarial environments well if you
think of the compute that's previously
been available it's been very CPU heavy
right because that's what the the
network sent and the consumer
applications accessor
we're now moving to a world where Asics
GPUs are becoming much more valuable and
I think you know I've talked about like
the idea to even go and start to get
legacy infrastructure companies under
your control and then start swapping the
CPUs out for GPUs a6 etc super
interesting
now it's also really it's a cost of
production game right so if we think
about vertical integration integrating
power production with manufacturing with
actually operating a facility right this
is the perfect oil and gas example I
spent you know seven years of my career
I started my life in building big
infrastructure projects that took 20
years to build and cost 20 to 40 billion
dollars yep
we look at the crypto space right if
this is truly gonna be a massive
industry that's heavily focused on
building new network infrastructure
that's resilience security centralized
whatever we need a physical expression
of that that's infrastructure financing
that's very different from financing a
protocol that's structured finance its
principle present interest and finding
new ways to effectively like
infrastructure financing is all about
reconciling the mismatch of cash flows
right you end up using a bunch of cash
but you don't get any in until five ten
years from now yep same thing in the
crypto space very few people have had
the vision in the foresight to
understand that that networking space
and that physical computer is so
critical well it was a it's actually how
I got involved in crypto I was how you
and I became friends what was what so my
family's been in the data center
business forever right and what I saw
was in the in the traditional data
center business space power hardware
operations right in biology
yeah in mining you have space power
hardware and operations it's just the
hardware's different right and the part
that got me was you can drive more yield
and take the same amount of risk right
and then you'd also deal with customers
you'll component that's because like
right now when people bid on compute
space yep on AWS right and when they're
doing that there's a limited amount of
margin you can capture and really the
amount of margin you can capture capture
is a function of demand right there's a
sign demand component people don't
recognize is mining is the same thing
but in addition to that supply and
demand sort of price point you also have
this inflationary reward right and so I
think what people aren't understanding
is the intractable relationship between
protocol design and physical compute
implementation and this is where I think
the idea of decentralization really
isn't truly possible until we find a way
to remove this compute infrastructure
constraint that's why I think like
really really new ideas around consensus
designs so I'll Grands gossip protocol
but gossip passing protocol she and
space mesh so there's very different
implementations of proof in space and
time even I think some of what file
points thinking about is really thinking
about like how do you disintermediate
and decentralize the compute layer and
to me that'll be the narrative that
dominates crypto from like 20 20 20 25 I
don't know wild ideas super fun though I
love is just such these are such fun
thorny problems and sometimes thinking
about them like makes me dizzy but yeah
that's really interesting for sure what
um what do you think it's gonna take for
the quote-unquote crypto world to
completely blur the line with the not
encrypted world and it's less about is
that a crypto project or not a crypto
project it's just is that something that
users are gonna use yeah I think we
haven't this is a really hard part okay
so what I always say is we figured out
how to create crypto assets we figured
out how to distribute them and sell them
through these new forms of capital
formation we figured out how to
speculate on them right like most of the
quote-unquote infrastructure the pics
travels people are investing in our
exchanges about financial speculation
well we haven't figured it out yet is
how to utilize this stuff and what we
haven't figured out yet is the
specificity between proof of stake
protocol a previous take protocol be
like what it's like a fork right a fork
is a very specific tool that you use for
very specific thing
what's the specificity for something
like Bitcoin versus something like Z
cash or Manero or - alright that
specificity narrative hasn't really
started to evolve yet because no one's
really using this stuff so I wrote this
post back in March of 2018 called
drowning in tokens and my whole premise
was that what we're doing right now is
we're just pumping out a ton of supply
but there's no demand
there's artificial demand and
speculative demand but there's no
utility demand and without a real demand
function you can't really model growth
mhm and and that's the problem until we
find natural demand for this stuff it's
very hard to see where the future might
go we can have ideas but we haven't seen
that many projects reach the mass market
and start to eat away at the market
share of payments companies or to
generate an entirely new type of demand
we just haven't seen that yet yep and
that's what's interesting and it goes
back to like these concepts that have
been around in the business school
community sorry where I come from for a
while like adoption curves the
innovation s-curve right it's really
China think about we're so early we're
either so earlier we're so late in the
adoption curve I actually don't know
anymore like maybe the total addressable
market for Bitcoin is really small maybe
that's just a reality and I think in its
current iteration the total addressable
for market market for Bitcoin is
actually quite small because it's too
hard to use right there are a limited
number of people have the competency and
the capacity and frankly the interest of
using it in its current iteration so
then it's technical innovation but also
product innovation that creates a larger
addressable market and I don't think
we've really started to think through
that yet people had ideas like when earn
calm went back when it was 21 came out
with their initial idea that was a cool
idea at the time right like I actually
thought that that could have been an
interesting way to spread adoption and I
know people laugh at the idea of
Mining with it a toaster kind of the
narrative that stuck it was actually a
really cool idea it was just way too
early and the form factor the 21
computer was way too hard yep and I
think they realized that and they were
like this site this is a great idea but
probably like two rows ten years to
nearly got it sorry that was like I'm
not very good at answering questions I
just listen you're you're you're
speaking your mind I love it so last
question for you what is the one who I
got to ask you questions at the end
go ahead three questions for pomp all
right go no no you asked me your last
question well what what's the one thing
you do on a regular basis either daily
or weekly that you think it has done the
most to inform your opinion about the
space go hang out with non crypto people
go to non crypto that's interesting any
specific types of events or people yeah
I love hanging out in the consumer
retail space like I think retail is
going through mass in a mass shift the
shift from physical to digital and
digital to virtual is a really
interesting one it's effectively we're
trying to do with crypto right we're
trying to take money from being physical
and digital to being truly virtual and
virtually native digitally native and
that's also happening in the retail
space and so I think it's really
interesting to spend a lot of time in
the retail space where everything people
do is driven by purpose and brand
alright like retails brand first
execution later
and everything in crypto is idea first
brand like never and so spending time in
the consumer space is really interesting
spending time in the arts and sort of
music space is really interesting there
are a lot of these really interesting
industries that are going through
fundamental shifts in how they reach
their market and sell and produce and
distribute product and to me it's really
interesting to hang out with people in
those communities and to go it like I
don't go in like let me talk to you out
don't like I hate that I have gone to so
many events where people are so pedantic
and they're like let me explain how
Bitcoin works I'm like these people
don't care I just like to go in and ask
people I'm like how do you know about
creating a strong brand what do you
think about every day when you go to
work like if you're the CMO of one of
the world's largest retail brands what
do you think about what do you think of
crypto like
what's your what's your perception of it
and what you'll find is people's
perception of Kryptos not that
flattering mm-hmm they're like it's
intriguing it's interesting but feels
real gross the feels unapproachable
feels weird so to me there's like this
really interesting kind of brand a
narrative problem and so it's just good
to get out of the crypto bubble and just
go spend time with people we think about
a totally different set of problems that
are very analogous what we're going
through that's not fun my favorite
people in those scenarios are the people
who have like their professional
perspective right and so they're like oh
you know it's all the people in the
basements and you know bad actors all
stuff and then as you're walking away
though I hate by the way which coin is
good to go up it's like their personal
question on the side people they want to
get rich quick but we all want that
money button where you just hit the
button and you're like give me that I'm
not gonna say what I said earlier with
the flash cash you know yeah yeah very
true I was told to keep it PG I did not
obey but but I think that mentality
right like inherently human beings are
self-interested of course I do I want to
put in the least amount of effort and
get the most amount of value out crypto
is perfect in that way and that's why
it's kind of in the perfect Trojan horse
everyone's like I can't really talk
about this but they're like I want to
make money I want to be rich and I don't
want to do [ __ ] to get there it's a
great incentive the great American Dream
yep
America baby what what uh I'll let you
ask me one question
what uh what question you want to ask
three I'd get scared okay
question number one I'm gonna be able
Sunday area because I can be okay
question number one um you have gone
from being fairly unknown in the crypto
space I don't say like when I first met
you I was like who's this pop guy - now
people talk about the pump as though
it's an adjective which I love like
kudos so ridiculous so you have engaged
in a very effective growth marketing
strategy yep what's your thought process
there so the man the pump tell us more
what one is I have a very unique
advantage in that I've worked on growth
at large
technology companies right so I
understand how I understand the pump I
understand how a lot of the algorithms
work etc I think that too is I'm a huge
believer that audience is currency right
in terms of if you have an audience it
doesn't have to be everyone but if
you're able to find like-minded
individuals you can use that to your
advantage
right and for those around you to the to
the advantage as well and then I think
the third thing is and I get a lot of
[ __ ] frankly for this is I think that a
lot of the people in this space are very
heavy and very talented the technology
side and so they tend to but I think
they are but there's a lot of
intellectual [ __ ] like man you're
wrong well and I guess that's every
industry but probably even more here
right and so what you get is you get
very like technical jargon you get like
the overly you know just kind of
conversation and so when I solve this I
said you know look our our business is
to manage money for investors right
mainly institutional investors and help
them get access to what we really think
of as the digital age so even the
blockchain age but we think that
blockchain and cryptocurrency Bitcoin
accessor is like 90 95 percent of that
today but I would argue that things like
Robin Hood or Robo advisors etc all are
you know an analogous to this world and
so the one area that I saw that nobody
was doing a good job of or at least not
doing it at scale was can you take these
highly technical concepts and basically
boil them down to the simplest form and
then share them with an audience and so
it's not really going after our hearts
and minds right I think that that's a
piece of it right as you is if you do
this successfully you may get some
hearts and minds but really it was just
I'm not smart enough to look at a very
technical white paper and understand
every single detail I want to reject
that notion
okay I think people in this space are
like oh well I'm not technical oh I'm
not smart enough yes you are like growth
marketing is a highly technical field it
is every field has a technical component
to it and I categorically reject the
notion that being technical in a non
engineering
feels not valuable I think you're just
just just to clarify it's not that I
think that non-technical people aren't
valuable what I think is that if you sit
me in a room and you say hey explain you
know zero knowledge proof and you bring
an engineer in they're going to be able
to explain it better than I am at a very
deep technical level now the difference
is exactly their audience is other
people like them who understand that
deep technical language my audience is
very different and so I think that by
focusing an understanding here's who I
want to talk to right now here's so that
that's helpful I think that that you
know look Twitter all stuff that's where
a lot of those people are who want that
message now the flip side of that right
and the people who detract from that
message are the people who are the deep
technical people who are like you're
dumb right like you're you're using
simple language you don't understand it
and so it's just the the disconnect
between I'm talking to a different
audience right and so at first you know
what something the Internet's a wild
place that's giving you [ __ ] on Twitter
I give you the most loyal of thing I was
like I love you look we could talk we
can talk about it you ready so so NLA
the context yes a pump so let me give
you my reaction this is great like
everyone loves tension I do I just [ __ ]
I also go okay I think was like March so
Dennis Loyola issued its own
cryptocurrency called your petrol that
was gonna be backed by its petroleum
reserves right and I like to call them
hunger tokens yeah it's terrible but you
have a legitimate reason for describing
it that way
yes but but I think what troubled me is
pumping out this tweet and you were like
mister tokenized the world spread the
virus which I love right easy succinct
messages but I do think it like they
rile up spread the virus sounds WAY
worse than the virus is spreading so so
pumping out this tweet that said the
virus is spreading like I look at
everyone adopting blockchain and
tokenization best example yet Venezuela
creating the petrol
and what you said actually was true but
it was a terrible example yep and I
think again it goes back to like there
are things that are correct
technically and then there are things
that are correct morally and my
objection wasn't on the correctness of
the statement her factual perspective it
was the fact that you had a really big
audience and this statement from like a
moral and subjective perspective was
just it felt like implicit endorsement
of something that was subjectively
horrific absolutely yeah and I think
that you know when you said when you put
it in that light first it was hey I
didn't think that me saying this
obviously is me endorsing the Venezuelan
government right but but but I think
part of it too is and this is something
that you know look I think we struggle
with a lot internally we talk about when
you're in an area where experimentation
is very important right there's going to
be people who try things that cross the
line or or push to an edge that you
don't agree with right now where's that
moral line etc and so it's how do you
encourage experimentation how do you
speak out against the bad applications
of the technology that's like an
expression of there are no sacred cows
right like there day we should be able
to experiment with anything and
everything even if it pushes the
boundaries of what currently is socially
accepted was I think that okay I think
the thing that we struggle with is well
here's the thing I think that we
struggle with is so there are probably
sacred cows right what if we actually
don't understand everything well enough
yet to know where those sacred cows are
well we don't know anything right that's
really the crux of this conversation is
actually know nothing all I know is that
I need to ask better questions and so
and that I need specificity so people
make statements like our protocols
decentralized qualify what decentralized
means so just think better questions and
like let's accept I agree with that we
don't we don't know what we don't know
and here's the really bad part of this
or even other areas where a lot of
technology is being experimental within
2n and applied is that
like if you looked at their blockchain
petrol solution versus what they're
doing outside of the blockchain space I
think that there would be a really deep
you know kind of emotional argument that
people would have on either side as to
which one was worse right which is
almost gets you down into now you're not
just talk about technology now you're
talking about you know human rights
sociology psychology the power of
government absolutely
one final plug I'm because I know we're
getting really along here this is why
representation on teams that are
building technology not agree the
technology I used today was largely
designed by people who don't look like
me who are not like me yep and the
problem is if we're going to
fundamentally disrupt money it can't be
a room of people who all look think feel
the same it has to be representative of
the people that 7 billion people seem to
be nine billion people who are going to
use it and that is the fundamental
problem is how we design technology
impacts how it gets used absolutely
there are material social political
economic and moral implications and this
is the problem with the tradition we're
like I want to blow [ __ ] up because I'm
tired with the existing power structure
because it does not serve me or people
who look like me and it's 2018 the fact
they were [ __ ] celebrating that women
can be GPS that venture funds is
pathetic it's so like people are like oh
let's congratulate ourselves first
female JPM like it's 2018 we've had
female presidents in almost every
country except America like let's get
with it this isn't the word sad we're
pathetic
what economy in the part that always you
know when it comes to so sad so that the
female argument right the immigrant
argument etc the part that I always have
a disconnect with people is its data
data proves that it is actually true if
you have a more diverse team right and I
forget all the data points but it's like
if there's a female on a public board
for example the company performs better
right if you know it that's what hire
someone with a vagina
to give them authority step 3 give them
capital like it's a three step there
goes the PG rating it's like I feel like
I'm taking crazy pills because I always
swear like it's so hard it's so
difficult like how do we change the
problem I'm like it's a three step
solution absolutely find people and hire
them one to give them authority in real
power three give them money I don't know
that's like that's pretty
straightforward
what do I know I'm just a crypto first
we will end there because I think that
is that is the general feeling if you
spend time in the crypto world and with
you know trishal asset managers etc is
you know the world as we know it going
forward I think is gonna look different
it's just trying to figure out what it
what it what is it actually going to end
up being absolutely alright thank you
thank you so much for doing this